[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée à la présidentielle en côte
d'ivoire nous sommes avec mamadou touré
le ministre de la promotion de la
jeunesse et de l'emploi des jeunes porte
parole adjoint du gouvernement
d'alassane ouattara candidat pour un
troisième mandat présidentiel le 31
octobre prochain
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions dans
cette grande interview
merci de nous avoir invité la
candidature du président alassane
ouattara suscite des tensions d'avoir
cette question est-ce que sincèrement
vous êtes certains que le scrutin du 31
octobre sera maintenu à la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu vous avez
une commission électorale indépendante
qui a un calendrier qui tient son
calendrier avant le scrutin du 31
octobre il ya différentes étapes et qui
est donc la révision de la liste
électorale
le dépôt des candidatures la plupart des
candidats sont en train de déposer la
candidature dans les délais requis avant
cela vous a vu la publication de la
liste provisoire qui a permis donc
d'ouvrir une phase du contentieux et
donc nous aurons donc dans quelques
jours la liste définitive
vous avez gardé qui est tenu et les
élections auront lieu les 31 octobre
justement cette question c'est parce
qu'un climat
particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire qui est suscitée par la
candidature du président alassane
ouattara pour ce troisième mandat et des
violences si ces violences s'aggravent
perdure comment la campagne électorale
est ce cette journée de scrutin dont
pouvoir se dérouler dans des conditions
idéales
alors là d'abord je vais rectifier la
tension artificiellement créée
aujourd'hui par une opposition n'est pas
du fait de la nature de ouattara 7
cette tension artiste crée du fait d'une
opposition qui est dans une logique anti
démocratique qui ne s'est pas préparé à
aller donc à des scrutins et ils se
trouvaient tous sortes de prétextes pour
justifier sa non participation à
l'élection présidentielle et qui a
décidé de se réfugier dans une violence
qui est totalement inacceptable
aujourd'hui ces activités de violence
ont été totalement circonscrite
d'ailleurs vous remarqué très bien que
le mode de la pollution n'ont pas été
suivies par les populations ivoiriennes
on assistait que guerrilla par ci par là
avec des dons des gamins qui brûlaient
des pneus dans des sous quartiers
d'abidjan en dehors donc de boue noire
où on a eu donc une manne de façon un
peu plus importante mais avec des dégâts
et des tueries totalement inacceptable
cette opposition d'apple l'adhésion des
populations ivoiriennes
ensuite nous avons nos forces de
sécurité pour faire le travail et qui
ont permis de maintenir donc un climat
d'inquiétudes et de paix sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
il ya quand même eu un
des victimes et l'opposition à son côté
mais si on avait deux tours et
l'opposition affirme de son côté que
elle manifeste pour contester le
troisième mandat du président alassane
ouattara
sa candidature est un militant descendre
dans la rue c'est ce que l'opposition
avait aucune manifestation dans le monde
entier et visant à passer à brûler et à
tuer des bêtes accepté lorsqu'on veut
manifester il ya des règles à respecter
lorsqu'on annonce démarche et qu'on ne
définit pas lui tenir et de la marche et
que on est on ne s'assure pas d'avoir
les autorisations préalables
leur ton pouce de julien son analyse est
allé casser puis tué c'est inacceptable
partout dans le monde et notre position
donc s'est montré totalement
irresponsable donc dans dans ce contexte
là et elle est responsable de ces
violences et d'effectuer riz et
d'ailleurs je m'étonne que qui
instrumentalisent qui met cette
opposition qui a su mentalise une
minorité dont deux jeunes et d'ailleurs
je mets tant que le président henri
konan bédié qui a été quand même un
ancien président de république qui a été
donc un homme d'état aujourd'hui lui
même donc l'un des responsables de cette
situation
alors justement dans camp d'henri konan
bédié au pdci on affirme que les
autorités de leur côté instrumental et
justement les violences qui ont lieu en
côte d'ivoire là qu est ce qu on
pourrait dire souvent tu as lease et
madame loscos pennetta au gros à laver
de la manifestation du siège du rhdp a
été attaqué et saccagé et brûlé les
premières victimes
donc à daoukro en trois l'ont été pour
lui une des deux victimes du camp de
l'opposition de du camp du parti au
pouvoir ont du rhdp est une autre
victime qui était dans une personne
d'origine étrangère
non vous savez on est dans la
manipulation perpétuelle ce que nous
avons tous constaté sait qu'il marche a
été annoncé
cette marche n'a pas eu l'autorisation
donc parce que la démarche et préalables
n'ont pas été effectuées nous avons
assisté à des actions de guérilla dans
le sous quartier d'abidjan ou de jules
apparaissait dans les rues brûlé des
pneus casser des bus pillet etc ont
pillé donc des véhicules etc et le rôle
du gouvernement et est donc de maintenir
donc la quiétude pour les populations
aujourd'hui nous avons un calme sur
l'ensemble du territoire et les
ivoiriens vaquent à leurs occupations
c'est que la situer la situation elle
doit tout de même inquiétante si le
gouvernement a décidé d'interdire les
manifestations au moins jusqu'au 15
septembre
ce que le gouvernement a interdit ce
sont les manifestants de rue puisque
elles se sont transformées à des
abandons de violence avec mort d'homme
madame ça c'est pas acceptable
mais le groupe à percer à persister a
dit que tous les rassemblements dans les
lieux clos son permis d'ailleurs nous
mêmes au nom du rhdp avoir des élèves
institut du président ouattara au stade
félix houphouet boigny plus de 5000
personnes
l'opposition dont elle a la possibilité
d'organiser des rassemblements mais dans
des lieux clos telle que définie par la
règle les rassemblements des partis
d'opposition des partis en lice pour
cette présidentielle ne sont pas
interdit les rassemblements ne sont pas
interdites sauf ceux qui le sont dans
l'âge mais vous comprenez bien vous
connaître les campagnes électorales
préélectorale heures dans beaucoup de
pays africains ça se passe très souvent
dans la rue vous le savez bien
oui mais l'évolution de la situation
sécuritaire permettra peut-être de
réévaluer cette situation nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que groupuscule
d'individus use de la violence pour
empêcher de nos citoyens de vaquer à
leurs occupations
il ya des arrestations également je
voudrais vous entendre là dessus
notamment sur l'arrestation de plus le
shérif
allez
avec plusieurs de ses proches c'est la
présidente d'une ong alternative
citoyenne ivoirienne
elle est si le procureur de la
république d'abidjan lui reproche
d'avoir tenu des propos incitant
notamment à l'insurrection civile et
militaire à la haine ethnique ou
religieuse pour ne citer que ces
accusations ses avocats dénoncent la des
arrestations arbitraires à l'encontre de
personnalités de la société civile
à partir du moment où une procédure
judiciaire est enclenchée
vous me permettrez de ne pas rentrer
dans un commentaire sur donc la
procédure judiciaire
mais de notre point de vue c'est qui est
inacceptable c'est que sous prétexte
donc une manifestation et d'expression
de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on incite au meutre
relisez les messages sur les pentes 4
réalisé donc les discours qui sont
tenues dans certains médias même en
ligne la part donc de certaines
personnes de cette opposition
sous prétexte de manifestations avec
expression démocratique il est
inacceptable
donc 2 comme je l'aï dit tantôt du pied
de tuer etc
je vous dis madame nulle part dans le
monde dont ce gendarme est acceptée
avant d'être leaders politiques avant
d'être résultat national sur les six
nuls avaient d'abord citoyen et en tant
que citoyen on est responsable de tous
les actes propose mais s'arrête partout
dans le monde on voit aussi des
organisations de la société civile
tenter de faire bouger les lignes
on peut se demander si vous ne craignez
pas finalement que tout cela vous
dépasse notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
non pas du tout pas du tout je vous ai
dit d'ailleurs cette position dans sa
velléité de créer lui d or d autres n'a
pas été suivi par les populations qui
veulent aujourd'hui après la grave crise
que nous avons connue en 2010 qui ne
demandent qu'à vivre tranquillement et à
participer au processus électoral
nous avons donc la liberté de choisir
donc le candidat
le pôle futur président de la république
donc il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
particulière
voilà ce que vous savez qu'il ya eu des
mouvements par exemple sénégal en 2012
le mouvement de la société civile y en a
marre aussi qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
bousculé à l'époque abdoulaye wade dont
la candidature était contestée plus
récemment on peut citer encore le
mouvement du 5 juin au mali on sait que
monsieur d'état militaire finalement qui
a renversé le président ibrahim boubacar
kéïta ça c'est vrai que ça peut
inquiéter au niveau de la côte d'ivoire
nous ne sommes pas d'abord dans le même
contexte un chaque pays a ses réalités
ne sont pas dans la même configuration
nous avons affaire à une minorité
d'individus qui refusent d'aller dans un
processus démocratique qui refusent
d'aller aux élections et qui ont décidé
de poser des actes d arpenter
démocratiques qui ont décidé donc qui se
réfugient aujourd'hui dans la violence
et qui ne peuvent pas prospérer
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu à la base un il ya
eu ce coup tragique du destin le décès
de l'ancien premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly qui était perçu comme l'homme
du consensus aussi bien par l'opposition
que par le pouvoir vous étiez proche
alassane ouattara ne s'était peut-être
pas trompé en le choisissant dites-nous
ce qu'il avait de si particulier qui
pourrait peut-être expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
non votre votre question à la benâte de
choses
amadou gon coulibaly était le candidat
du rhdp choisi à l'unanimité dans des
cadres du rhdp nous avons eu un conseil
politique le 12 mars et nous avions
demandé
donc opposants à tresques avait décidé
de se retirer que notre nous
souhaiterons amadou gon coulibaly soit
le candidat
le choix de la majorité écrasante
majorité des cadres du rhdp
des militants du rhdp a été portée dont
sur amadou gon coulibaly
de par sa compétence il a géré pendant
trois ans le gouvernement ivoirien avec
tous les résultats que nous avons
obtenus d'énormes progrès au niveau
économique au niveau social de par les
valeurs de loyauté qu'il a développés il
a quand même eu très longtemps donc
auprès du président ouattara auprès de
qui il a appris amadou gon était
quelqu'un d'une très grande humilité qui
était un assembleur qui est un vrai chef
d'équipé qui était le président du
directoire du rhdp donc il ya manager s
est une grosse famille politique
on est en tout de lui tous ces cadres
venant d'horizons divers donc l'ensemble
de cette qualité donc nous amener à
solliciter dans sa candidature est donc
le conseil politique la vallée la nature
d'amadou gon coulibaly
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé
quasiment à un mois et demi donc de la
date de clôture des candidatures
1e - demi de la date de clôture des
candidatures
il se poser à nous nous dira j'ai fait
beaucoup de défis trouver un candidat
qui pourrait donc au delà de la
compétence fédérer autour de lui
l'ensemble des militants des cadres pour
aller donner ces élections que nous
avons dit pour relever le défi de notre
union de notre unité en vue des
garanties donc notre victoire le 31
octobre
il n'y avait que la personne du
président c'est ouattara qui à nos yeux
étaient donc la personne idoine pour
porter donc notre notre dame nature et
la nature du rhdp
d'abord ça nous permettait d'ondés réglé
donc
l'équation d'une union du défi de
l'union à notre sein ensuite pour nous
cette candidature permet donc de
garantir la stabilité pour ce pays parce
que n'oubliez pas que nous évoluons km
dans un contexte international qui est
un peu difficile avec tout ce que vous
avez cités avec donc toutes les
velléités des djihadistes et caetera et
caetera et la kouadio a besoin d'un
leadership fort et pour nous ce faisant
le buzz on va travailler quand celui
d'hergé
mamadou touré on va marquer une courte
pause et on va se retrouver dans un
instant à tout de suite pour la suite de
cette grande interview sur rtl france
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec mamadou touré le ministre de
la promotion de la jeunesse et de
l'emploi des jeunes en côte d'ivoire
porte parole du gouvernement d'alassane
ouattara en lice pour un troisième
mandat présidentiel le 31 octobre
on parlait justement de cette
candidature d'alassane ouattara vous
étiez en train d'expliquer pourquoi il
s'était présenté à la suite justement du
décès du premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly
très sincèrement on se demande aussi si
le rhdp ne disposez pas d'un plan b il
ya des personnalités au sein du rhdp on
peut citer par exemple
le successeur d'amadou gon coulibaly
hamed bakayoko qui est actuellement
premier ministre toujours ministre de la
défense ou encore adama bictogo le
directeur exécutif du rhdp
toutes ces personnalités ne sont pas à
la hauteur de la magistrature suprême
dans le pr ne se pose pas en termes d'
être à la hauteur ou pas nous avons
énormément de cadres qui ont été formés
par les présences en ouattara je vous
dis que nous avons nous avions le défi
de notre unité
vous savez une victoire des ponts de
l'unité joue dans l'exemple la
présentielle ici en face vous avez eu
donc à la dernière présidentielle des
partis politiques importants qui n'ont
pas su faire l'unité qui ont organisé
des primaires avec des cadres qui
étaient tous présidentiable mais qui se
sont entre déchirés et qui n'ont pas pu
gagner la présidentielle donc la
compétence est une chose mais l'unité en
plus de la compétence et une autre chose
et nous disons qu'aujourd'hui le seul à
même de fédérer tout le monde dans un
dans une dynamique c'est le présent
sinon à tavannes d'ailleurs les cadres
que vous avez cités ont tous appelé à la
tentative du président ouattara l'a
justement par rapport donc à ce défi
d'unités au délà donc du rhdp dans
dans le contexte actuel nous estimons
que l'opposant ouattara est celui qui a
le leadership nécessaire pour faire face
aux défis qui se posent à nous tant au
niveau interne ou externe
donc il ne s'agit pas donc de compétence
c'est 4 que vous citez sont compétents
il y en a d'autres aussi qui sont très
compétents à un mois et demi du dépôt
des candidatures je mets au défi
n'importe quel parti politique de
pouvoir faire ce test décisif de trouver
un candidat qui fédère et tous les
cadres et tous les to le mitage et au
curry puisque vous avez reçu nos
adversaires ici sur votre chaise prenez
deux parties qui sont en face de nous la
même question pourrait être posée le fp
tendance laurent gbagbo continue de
réclamer la candidature de laurent
gbagbo
malgré la situation difficile dans
laquelle ils se trouvent à rapport donc
avec la justice internationale etc
on aurait pu leur toi qu'est la question
sa voix mais pourquoi ils n'arrivent pas
eu à trouver au sein du rpi un cadre
compétent qui sont un plan b à ba beau
le président henri konan bédié à 90 ans
a dû mettre en place un poids électoral
au sein de son parti qui a exclu tous
les autres candidats pour être le
candidat unique donc donc au sein de son
parti
on doit puisque vous accueillir sa voix
mais pourquoi le besoin qu'on a bidias
90 ans n'a pas su trouver des cadres
compétents dans ce sont des questions
heureusement que l'on a que l'on a posé
un local dans les bateaux mais si on
s'allonge
en ce qui nous concerne donc je vous le
dis en toute transparence
nous avions donc cette mort brutale
d'amadou gon à un mois et demi du dépôt
de candidature nous a posé donc un
problème au niveau de notre capacité à
nous fédérer à nos unis autour d'un
autre candidat est l'élément fédérateur
chez nous et tous les militants tous les
cas blonde et sur le présent sans retard
ça ce sont les raisons politiques de
cette candidature sur la question de
l'illégalité et l'illégitimité de ce
troisième mandat
quels sont les arguments pour le
justifier il ya une réforme de la
constitution en 2016
votre
le point de vue de votre camp c'est de
dire les compteurs sont à zéro on
recommence mais nous avons une nouvelle
constitution
nous sommes dans la troisième république
d'ailleurs tous nos adversaires sont
d'accord à l'époque à dire que nous
étions dans une nouvelle république nous
sommes dans une troisième en public et à
partir de ce moment le président
ouattara pour cette candidature octobre
2020 serra à sa première candidature
sous la troisième république
et s'il avait eu il sera à son premier
mandat sous la troisième république
après il ya des points de vue divergent
donc qui est membre de l'opposition
c'est leur droit
ce que nous disons c'est que chacun puis
à l'idée son interprétation de la
constitution
d'ailleurs les juristes ils vont de
l'interprétation dans un sens ou dans un
autre
nous avons un juge constitutionnel qui
est le seul habilité à trancher sur la
question et son et démocrates
c'est parce qu'on aussi respectueux dans
des institutions et des lois mais on se
référera donc au juge conditionnelle qui
décidera alors cette fois vous dit vous
avez vous allez vous référer au juge
constitutionnel en 2010 la cour
constitutionnelle elle s'était prononcée
pour réfuter les résultats à l'époque de
la commission électorale après
l'élection et le rhdp toute l'alliance
au footy s'est opposé justement à la
décision de la cour constitutionnelle
alors même le conseil constitionnel même
la cour constitutionnelle quant à une
décision elle obligée de se baser sur la
loi c'est kate est annoncé en 2010 pas
seulement par le rhdp
mais par tout le monde la com et et
nationales et c'est ce que le conseil
console elle est décidé d'invalider une
partie des résultats d'une partie donc
du territoire national en violation de
ce que la loi disait la loi 10 en 2010
que si des irrégularités étaient
constatées par le conseil
constitutionnel et que c'est une égalité
étaient d'une nature à entacher la
crédibilité du scrutin
elle devait annuler l'ensemble du
scrutin et non annulé une partie donc du
scrutin et d'ailleurs le président de
cette cour a dû revenir sur sa décision
a dû s'expliquer
voilà donc ce n'est pas de la même si on
n'est pas dans la même situation
il s'agit aujourd'hui donc pour cette
cour de donner un avis sur d'aucune
disposition constitutionnelle est
d'ailleurs sénégal dans madame on se
retrouve dans la même configuration
savait que le présent watts avait
procédé à une modification de la
constitution à la mise en place d'une
nouvelle constitution le président wade
dont ses opposants avaient contesté sa
légitimité sa légalité et la légalité
donc après les candidats le juge
constitutionnel a tranché dans le sens
que les faisans oies des pour être prêt
vous pouvez être candidat il a été
candidat
une partie de l'opposition a boycotté le
président macky sall et halo scrutin
avec le président wade il a gagné les
élections aujourd'hui c'est le présent a
que ça qui est candidat ce débat en or
au delà de ces débats ce sont les wings
ce que je vais faire reçoit des sections
des soins qu'ils votent c'est ceux qui
parlent qui sont les positions qui ne
sont pas une incohérence près sont sûrs
qu'ils ont la majorité des ivoiriens
avec eux allons aux élections
laissons les auriez choisi qui sera le
plaisir toujours la question de
l'indépendance de cette cour
constitutionnelle qui se posent
l'indépendance par rapport à voir mais
ce n'est pas la cour constitutionnelle
va se prononcer ainsi les candidatures
donc l'interprétation qui a fait là donc
la constitution et l'analyse qu'elle
ferait de ce camp nature mais c'est pas
le conseil consumer report c'est bien
les aurains qui votent pas d'élection
pour laurent gbagbo l'ancien président
ivoirien son acolyte charles blé goudé
idem
même chose pour l'ex chef des forces
rebelles guillaume soro puisque la
commission électorale indépendante à
lézat rayés des listes électorales a
rejeté le recours de quelques-uns
d'entre eux ça ça peut être perçu aussi
par leur électorat parce qu'il ya quand
même une base fidèle à laurent gbagbo à
charles blé goudé à guillaume soro ça
peut être perçu comme une humiliation
moi je ne veux pas rentrer dans une
interprétation des procédures vous avez
un état de droit madame sont aussi des
règles vous avez un code électoral qui a
été adoptée qui a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale et dans le code électoral
il est prévu que toute personne qui
il fait l'objet d'une condamnation
définitive ne puisse pas être lancée
retourner c'est pas une loi qui visait
personnellement les personnes qu'ils
avaient cité ce que le président la
commission électorale a expliqué ce que
en pareille circonstance la commission
électorale écrit au ministère de la
justice pour avoir la liste entre deux
révisions la liste électorale pour la
liste de tous les condamnés défini de
façon définitive et toutes ces personnes
sont dans un premier temps sorti de la
liste
elles ont la possibilité de faire un
recours auprès donc la commission
électorale indépendante ou don de la
justice mais il leur revient dans de
suivre la procédure moi je sais pas de
fonctionnalités sont sous le coup
laurent gbagbo charles blé goudé il ya
une procédure encore en cours allaient
qui n'est pas achevée au moment où on se
parle mais ils sont aussi sous le coup
d'une procédure judiciaire en côte
d'ivoire l'opposition réclame leur
amnistie pour laurent gbagbo précisément
son épouse simone gbagbo demande
alassane ouattara d'amnistié laurent
gbagbo
on se souvient d'ailleurs en qu'en 2006
laurent gbagbo il avait de fait revenir
alassane ouattara au pays 1
telle est la position aujourd'hui du
gouvernement ivoirien sur l'amnistié
notre position c'est que tant que nous
avons des procédures qui sont pendantes
à la justice nous refusons nous nous
refusons tout commentaire toute
immixtion dans les procédures
judiciaires
vous avez rappelé vous même
contrairement à tout ce qui est dit la
procédure à la cpi n'est pas terminée
laurent gbagbo bénéficie d'une liberté
conditionnelle
il ya un recours qui encourt donc auprès
du juge d'appel qui doit se prononcer il
faut laisser donc tous les processus est
terminé
et quand tous ces produits sont dues
seront terminés en ce moment peut-être
l'opposant ouattara donc va aviser
mais pour l'heure vous avez des
procédures en cours et nous nous
refusons dont pas principe tout
commentaire sur le procédé est ce que
vous vous dites
que l'opposition a raison que le retour
de laurent gbagbo de charles blé goudé
de guillaume soro leur amnistie leur
retour au pays c'est une question
cruciale pour sceller la réconciliation
nationale en côte d'ivoire
mais moi j'ai même entendu certains de
vos confrères dire que s'alarmer pour
dire que si laurent gbabo et du standard
quand as-tu importantes dédiées etc ne
sont pas candidats à l'élection
présentielle ça ou la voit donc à la
violence jeudi je suis pas d'accord
rappelez-vous que en 2010
tous les codes important était temps
d'aller sont pris dans ciel sans
empêcher la violence
donc c'est pas la question de la
violence l'instabilité ne se pose pas en
termes d'ambitions personnelles de tel
ou tel
cela m en plus de notre posture de notre
de nos discours et pour responsable et c
est ce qu on voit que par exemple des
violences communautaires en côte
d'ivoire encore aujourd'hui ça veut dire
que peut-être que la réconciliation
nationale
elle n'est pas scellé non la
réconciliation est un processus
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez la
situation en 2011
au moment où l'opposant ouattara qui
cédait donc à la maja suprême et que
vous prenez la situation aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
la plupart des réfugiés de la sous
région sont revenus en côte d'ivoire
plus de 90% des refuges et sont revenus
avec des enfants qui ont été scolarisés
des milliers de victimes ont été
indemnisées par le gouvernement ivoirien
certains réfugiés ont retrouvé leur
emploi dans l'administration publique
etc sont autant d'actes qui ont été donc
posé par le gouvernement
on est curieux de savoir en contrepartie
quels sont les actes posés par cette
opposition
quand vous prenez une dame comme simone
ehivet gbagbo qui a bénéficié justement
du processus réconciliation à travers
l'onuci dont elle a bénéficié
mais qui aujourd'hui encore des discours
rétrograde et xénophobe
dur et j'ai donc d'une partie des
ivoiriens de l'étranger cela
inacceptable
donc ça veut dire qu'on aura malgré
toute la bonne volonté du gouvernement
et tous les acteurs étaient posées si en
face nous n'avons pas des personnes qui
sont réceptives et qui elles mêmes sont
dans une dynamique de réconciliation au
niveau politique
ça sera difficile mais au niveau des
populations et vers les occupations
d'ailleurs les velléités
d'instrumentalisation des populations
pour amener la communauté à s'entre
déchirer entre elle n'a pas prospéré
parce que les voyons aujourd'hui dans
leur grande majorité veut vivre en paix
ne veut plus revivre ce qu'on a connu en
merci beaucoup à vous mamadou touré je
rappelle que vous êtes le ministre de la
promotion de la jeunesse et de l'emploi
des jeunes en côte d'ivoire porte-parole
adjoint du gouvernement d'alassane
ouattara en lice donc pour un troisième
mandat le 31 octobre prochain
merci à vous merci beaucoup et merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette grande
interview une grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver en podcast sur nos
réseaux sociaux notre site internet
rt france point tv merci de votre
attention et à très bientôt
il
[Musique]